good greedy that visits the glass I'm
Kelly Gruber another look at that book
her play he hears the whistle you knew
she was going to pass it didn't notice
that there was the player he was fast
and too wasn't available just throws it
over the game Devon knows it get there
get the ball up and in can't jump I
might be afraid take that take it again
get some of that but you got to start to
pick him up right here because now he's
coming at full speed and look at this
opening in the lanes there is no one
there to make him not type atmosphere
and kind of intensity that you bad angle
but Devon Booker is not worried about no
angle falling away going sideways got
long you can go over and talk to the
official and they can explain it to you
Devon thought he got fouled by Knox on
that way and
it's great concentration fire is tough
but when you going toward the ramp the
young player think that's what people
don't get he's going full-speed there on
this three he didn't jump up these can
offer fall
destroy
he fights who hits on his arm and then
hands he'll give Devin out of the game
but that's a tough shot right there
give him the 41 well deserved he sees
the opportunity
when the Knicks look like they were
gonna get out in front and get a lead